and we've teamed up with choices matter  APIs era Biosciences educational  campaign to show you the premiere of a  new documentary Gateway make money buy  the pills that was my life  the documentary follows three families  who have struggled with opioid addiction  after surgery specific leaves nobody  starts I believe with heroin I don't  think anybody wakes up and says yeah I  think I'll become a heroin addict today  for more information head over to  Gateway film.com  the film is presented by choices matter  so choices matter is an education  campaign to educate consumers and  patients about non-opioid options to  manage pain after surgery there's a lot  of redemption at the end of our stories  of hope and yeah everyone seems to be in  a really good place or getting there  which is really wonderful to see I was  tired of heating myself and I was just  ready to surrender